في دراسه اجريت على الفئران عام 2021 وجدت
ان بعض الانماط الجينيه كانت مسؤوله ان
تعيش الفئران لفتره اطول عند تقييد فترات
اطعامها بمواعيد محدده دراسه اخرى لعام
2019 وجدت ان توقف عن الطعام لمده التراوح
بين 12 و16 ساعه يمكن ان يزيد من افرازه
هرمون الجريلين وهو المسؤول عن احساسنا
بالجوع والذي بدوره يحفز تكوين خلايا
دماغيه جديده
الصيام ايضا مسؤول عن تحسين الادراك
والمزاج العام حيث يمكن ايضا ان يبطئ
التدهور في وظائف المخ ويقي من مرض
الزهايمر كما ان التوقف عن الطعام لفترات
محدده يمكن ان يقلل من مستويات القلق
واحتمالات الاصابه بعدد من الاضطرابات
العصبيه وفقا لدراسه نشرت عام 2013 حيث
اظهر ثلاثه اطفال مصابين بالصرع خضعوا
للصيام المتقطع تحسنا في السيطره على
النوبات
[موسيقى]